you
[Music]
yeah thanks let me be here today I'm
excited to share some of our work on
explainable I specifically applied to
science and medicine I'm defending you
dub here this course so just about
wrapping up can I work with suing Lee if
you happen to know her over in the
Kampai lab there and you know computer
science so maybe you guys this group
that are very well sympathetic to this
question but I like to start out and ask
you know why do we care about explain
ability in ml it's a lot of our work has
focused on this and to take a look at
that we can start with just a simple
example of a guy named John he's a
typical bank customer and like most
customers today
whenever you interact with a company
oftentimes data about you ends up
getting sent into some kind of model and
in this case if you're in a financial
institution often these models are
trying to predict things that you care
about in terms of outcomes so in this
case predicting whether John has any
repayment problems so here a chance 55%
leads to the bank denying his loan okay
so in this case this sort of a standard
thing that happens thousands of times
every day around the world and it leads
to questions from John obviously like
why did you deny my loan if you have a
good manager you should also ask the
same question right why are we making
these really business critical decisions
but unfortunately sometimes for the data
scientists who came in building this
model was all about accuracy for them
and so they don't have good answers
sometimes when they're trying to explain
what's going on here so why does this
happen well it happens often because
many times you run into a trade-off
between a complex model where because
you have a very very large potentially
you know complicated data set you can
take advantage of the flexibility these
complex models and get a lot of accuracy
but that can lead to a lack of interpret
ability in contrast some simple models
can be interpreted well in the right
contexts but if they're too restrictive
they'll lead to a lack and accurate lack
of accuracy okay this is what often
leads people to run into this in
practice particularly in finance and so
if you have interpret ability or
accuracy and you can only choose one
that's a painful trade-off for the bank
is particularly painful because accuracy
directly corresponds to money for them
because accuracy will correspond to
default rates for their loans but
interpretability has really important
these are wonderful icons that are
different on Mac and Windows but this is
meant to be a happy person so like if
you're interpreting you have a happy cuz
we're happy manager there's also really
important legality concerns with gdpr
and other things so this is a very there
are strong drivers on both sides of this
radar for the many companies now one
thing you can do is try and make simple
models better right so that you can
improve their ability to retain
interpret ability and also move towards
accuracy and that's a great approach
we're actually going to focus on the
other one though which is basically
taking what's already considered very
complex models and trying to move
extract interpretability from them okay
so if you do that though and you just
look at a complex model by itself it
could be very complicated in the mapping
and trying to explain an entire mapping
space could just be hopelessly complex
so instead what we're gonna do is focus
on explaining individual predictions one
at a time because those involve perhaps
just a small piece of the overall
complexity of the model so I don't have
to describe how a model behaves in all
circumstances in order to tell John what
was going on with his loan I just need
to tell him what was going on that
affected him so if we do that one way to
go about it is to say let's start with a
simple model and see what this means be
really specific kind of concrete so
here's a linear model why do we consider
these things interpreted well often it's
because they have this giant summation
sitting in the middle of the model right
so we have a bunch of terms coming in
these are things about John let's say
these input attributes and then a bunch
of terms come together and they just get
summed up and sent through some output
okay so we think of these as
interpretable because we can look at
that and see a bunch of things coming
together additively
and what's coming into the summation can
be kind of viewed as a credit that's
attributed to each input feature in
contrast if we look at complex models
say a neural net or you know random
forest may be Grady booster decision
trees things like this often there's so
much going on in there that there's not
a nice term that we can just sort of
surface and say ah this is how the model
is going so what we're going to talk
about is how we can explain an
individual prediction in a way very
similar to how a linear model works
where again we're gonna have a summation
sitting inside there but now instead of
having just terms that are straight from
the definition of the model we're gonna
have to come up with our own definition
of a credit attributed to each feature
okay so this fee function is going to be
indexed by the feature and it depends
both on the model and the current input
okay so we're essentially replacing the
input to a summation that you would get
in a linear model with
something that represents the importance
of that feature in the complicated
moment okay so this is sort of the high
level motivation this where we can look
this and this is actually really just a
form of an explanation if you think
about this I said eventually what we're
doing is you're saying why did this
model make this prediction they say well
whenever you give an explanation has to
have some form and this is the forum
we're saying it has and you know perhaps
not surprisingly this form has been used
by a lot of previous methods okay this
is something we noted before so lime
from Marco here uses this approach and
there's a variety of methods here from
Shapley values based on ideas from game
theory then I'll get back to that are
really interesting also produce
explanations of this form these are all
model agnostic but there's also ones
that are specific to particular popular
model types that are typically hard to
explain so Tsubasa's one targeted at
trees also came out of Microsoft here
and then there's a variety that target
deep learning methods all of them come
out with explanations that look like
this they have a sum of sort of feature
attribution values that they sum up and
represent the output so this is
interesting and people hadn't previously
appreciated this unity among the methods
and so we named this class the class of
additive feature attribution methods
which is nice because it gives you some
connection and understanding about how
this part of the literature relates to
one another but you can learn a lot more
than that as well because it turns out
there's various strengths and weaknesses
in these in these methods one really
nice thing about these approaches based
on game theory is that they're not is
that they come as like the unique
solution to a set of properties that can
be specified in terms of fairness and
when you're explaining something
fairness as defined by these properties
turns out to be really really useful so
we'll get back to that in contrast these
other methods so I should mention these
are nice because of that but they can be
a bit slow okay because of the way they
have to be computed in contrast these
other methods are typically based on
what could be viewed as a bit more
heuristic approaches but they tend to be
much faster okay so in one side you have
some better theoretical grounding but
slower computation the other side you
have faster estimation but less
guarantees so what we have attempted
do is combine these strings together to
propose a method that we call shop and
this is something we presented at nipson
2017 so in order to find this we need to
say what how do we define these feature
attributions okay so I talked about
we're gonna make an explanation by
summing together a set of values that
represent the importance of each input
how can we define those things how do we
define the credit let's go back to John
so for explaining to John why his loan
was denied and we're gonna do it using
this type of explanation of course there
are many other types you could use it's
good to start at a base rate okay so in
this case we have a base rate of 20% and
this is just how often do people get
their loans tonight just on average okay
so that's kind of a base rate of loan
rejection or at least trouble in
repayment and now the prediction for
John was 55% right so if we're going to
explain what's so special about John
what we need to do is explain how he got
from the base rate to our current
prediction right because if we predicted
20% there might have not been anything
special about John just we always
predict 20% okay but when John says why
am i 55% what we really have to explain
is this 35% difference here okay so how
can we do this well if we assume our
models fairly accurate then we should
just take the expected value of the
output of our model that's going to be
the base rate okay so we can just say
what's the expected value of the model
let's say over our training data set and
that's the base rate and then what we
can do is since this is an expectation
we can just introduce a term into that
conditional expectation and that term
here we'll say let's see we conditioned
on the fact that he is 20 years old so
when we conditioned on the fact that
John's 20 his risk jumps up by 15% well
we can attribute that 15% jump if we'd
like to John's age now we can
conditioned on the fact that he's a day
trader that's a very risky profession
and that jumps up to 70% then we
condition the fact the only has one open
account like a waiting financial
disaster but he made a ton of money in
the stock market last year so as capital
gains pushes him down to 55% so what
we've done is we've de physically
divided up how we got from here to here
by conditioning one at a time on all the
features until we've conditioned in all
of them which means we're course gonna
be the output of the model
so any questions at this point or good
questions so let me let me start here
with let's assume they're independent
for the moment and let's talk about
whether the model itself is linear or
non-linear because both of those are
going to impact how this works because
this is not the final way we want to do
this because the order really matters as
we introduce these things okay either if
they're independent or you don't
dependent between the input features or
if the model itself is nonlinear so
let's assume that the inputs are fairly
independent for the moment and just
think about maybe there's particularly
bad to be a young day trader okay and if
that's the case there could be some sort
of interaction effect between day trader
and age and then what would have
happened here is that when we saw age we
don't know you're a day trader yet but
when we see a day trader we already know
you're an age so we get the extra boost
from that interaction effect maybe it's
particularly bad to be a young day
trader and if we were to reverse the
order age we'll get the interaction
effect and day trader won't okay so
there's potentially you know n factorial
different ways of allocating credit if
you were just to start throwing things
in one at a time into the ordering
yep yeah good question so if you take
there's two ways to go about it one is
if you because what you're getting at is
the challenge of being able to fully
estimate the whole joint conditional
Joint Distribution because in order to
compute this exactly you would have to
know the full joint distribution of the
input features and then you could
compute all these conditional
expectations you know in practice I
don't think it's wise to assume you can
do that at least accurately so in
practice what happens is you often
assume independence between different
input features in order to calculate the
conditional expectation well so let's
say for example we go back here so we've
introduced age okay now what makes this
tricky is if age is conditionally
dependent with other features that would
make it hard okay in order to impute all
the other features but if I assume
independence between x1 and all the
other X's I can simply run an
expectation over just those terms and
now if I assume independence between x1
and x2 I can do the exact same thing
again does that make sense yeah okay or
I can go sequentially where the ordering
literally matter and I'm going to be
kind of increasing my condition and each
step
for a given problem how do you decide
which way you are are you kind of
imagining conditional independence
between the variables somehow or just
sticking and assuming one and going with
that yeah so in this case here we'll
compute this expectation by simply
taking the mean over the dataset okay so
just evaluate your model on the entire
training dataset take the mean you're
done in this set here what we can do is
we can say well John is 20 years old so
one way to do this is kind of like a
partial dependent spot kind of approach
you simply plug 20 in and then plug for
all the other values everything that's
in your training dataset and you'd get
that now that makes an independence
assumption between age and the other
features and so that's an assumption
that we are making and then you can
repeat that here where now you're fixing
you know age to be 20 employment to be
day-trader and then you sample from the
rest of the features again independent
from these two yes you do need a model
you don't need the generative model of
the input data but you do need to be
ability to re-evaluate the model you're
explaining because that's gonna gain you
new labels yeah yeah which is that I can
think about all the different summed
contributions
independently and in sort of a informal
sense right yep you know particularly
I'm thinking about the actionability for
poor John here right yeah John gets
denied yeah let's know what can I do
right and maybe the last thing on the
list was like
or something which is something I you
know changing my occupations maybe open
accounts it's not just what's going to
happen if I open account it's going to
be what's happened yeah yeah exactly so
hold on that for this sec if you don't
mind and yeah the other exits yes well
so the dependence is driven by the
nonlinearities in the model not by the
input distribution in the sense that
like let's imagine I have an and
function the order will matter even if
my input features are independent
because whenever I see the second one in
my and function that's going to change
my model so the only way that the
ordering will not matter is if all of my
input features are independent and my
model is linear so nonlinear models are
what we care about explaining and so
that's why the order matters which gets
back to what you're saying about why I
don't want to have a reason about
orderings when I'm looking at an
explanation and there are many ways to
be ordering it's not even a good way to
pick the right ordering necessarily so I
think this is a good place to actually
step back and ask have other people
asked this question before if other
people asked is there a good way to
allocate responsibility among a set of
inputs to a function for the output of
that function and turns out that you
know perhaps not surprisingly there have
been people who thought about that and
if you look back in the 1950s there's a
guy named Lloyd Shapley who worked on
this in the context of cooperative game
theory and there the idea was to say we
have a set of players that are coming
together and they're gonna play a
cooperative game and at the output of
this game is going to be let's say some
money and I need to divide that money
among the players in a fair way but
these people they interact
differently so some people clearly
deserve more than others how can I
fairly divide that money and it turns
out you can extend that it doesn't have
to just be positive values like money
you can just be any output of the
function and when you do that you know
proach that a variety of ways but the
way Lloyd approached it was he said let
me write down some properties about
fairness that I think should hold and if
I write down it turns out only a few
properties about fairness there's only
one way to divide up the money such that
these fairness properties are not
violated and that I think it's really
compelling he did a lot of good work on
this and a bunch of other things got a
Nobel Prize in 2012 so this is like an
economics kind of thing but these are
very very well known values called the
Shapley values now that are the unique
solution to these fairness properties
okay and that's what gets that how do we
get around this whole dependence on
ordering okay so what are these
properties first of all that he wrote
down and these are actually some later
properties updated in the 80s because
they're a bit easier to connect with
machine learning but one of them is
called local accuracy or add activity
from game theory and essentially it's
pretty straightforward it just says
you're setting a set of feature
attributions I want it to sum up from
the base value to the output of the
model okay so if you're giving me some
summation I would like the sum of these
local feature attributions the some of
these feve al use to equal this to this
and that's kind of the thing we set out
to start at the beginning is to explain
that difference so it's kind of a
natural property we'd like to hold I
mean you can certainly violate it but
let's assume we would like this to hold
for our explanation then the second
property here is called consistency or
monotonicity in game theory and for this
one essentially what it says is that if
you were to have a model and then you're
gonna reach in and make that model
depend more on a feature then your
attribution for that feature shouldn't
go the other way it shouldn't actually
decrease okay and this is really
important because if you violate
consistency it means you can't trust any
of the future orderings in your
attributions even within the same model
so really this is kind of a core like
don't be wrong kind of axiom and then
there are a couple others that are
basically trivial in ml they're always
they're just sort of like I'm allowed to
swap input features I'm allowed to you
know zero means zero things like that so
these are the two fundamental properties
that really define these values and what
are these values well they're easy to
say very easy to specify
and it's the Shapley values result from
averaging exactly I just told you to do
except overall and factorial possible
orderings so for every ordering I'm
gonna get a fee one I'm gonna get n
factorial fee will fee ones whenever I
introduce the first feature and whatever
position and then I just average those
okay so it's very simple to say but of
course very painful to compute you
wouldn't actually want to enumerate all
in factorial possible orderings in order
to get this result so it's natural to
ask the question maybe there's a way to
do this faster quicker easier how do we
do this well it turns out it then be
hard so it's a couple options we have
for np-hard problems that we're trying
to you know we want they're like really
motivated perhaps by the theory and we
really wanted to hold but you know how
do we approach this to solve this for
ammo well one of course is to prove that
P equals NP that's one option and the
other is to find an approximate solution
and I really thought this would help our
nips paper a lot in the impact but no so
we we focused on an approximate
solutions and in reality like an
approximate solution is pretty trivial
if you just look at the problem right
it's a n factorial things and picking a
mean just draw out random samples from
that those number of permutations right
and that's exactly what previous methods
have done basically they say we're have
a certain number of permutations let's
just draw maybe one hundred a thousand
permutations for each feature and then
we'll take an average okay but what
we're gonna do here is say we can do
better okay and how can we do better by
looking at the unification that we just
talked about and trying to draw
strengths from some other methods and in
particular you know there are
connections with all these methods but
I'm gonna focus on the connection with
lime and talk about how we used some of
the advantages in lime to improve our
ability to estimate these classic values
in game theory so maybe you guys are
familiar with this but if you don't
remember what marker wrote miss paper
he's got a minimization function it
looks kind of like this we're
essentially you're trying to fit a
linear model locally to your original
model that you're trying to explain it's
not important the details here but what
is important is that you have parameters
you need to choose okay you have to pick
a loss function that sort of pushes
these things close to each other you
have to pick some kind of regular and
most importantly have to pick a local
kernel that defines what local means
okay and you know perhaps naturally you
just sort of choose these things
heuristically when you're trying to
build this type of explanation method
but if we go back and we say ah now we
know that if our set function you know
for dealing with sort of toggles type
inputs then we're gonna be inside this
class and that means that all these
parameters are forced right there's only
one answer that matches these axioms so
that means there must be only one set of
parameters that we can choose in order
to maintain our local accuracy and our
consistency so that's a non constructive
statement but whoa this is a difference
between Mac and Windows there is a
formula that we derived or
simultaneously checking a consistency
between Mac and Windows PowerPoint here
so this formula here is essentially a a
specific local waiting kernel that we
derived that allowed us to estimate the
Shapley values in a new way okay so
these are values that have been around
for you know better part of a century
but now we can estimate them using
linear regression which is fundamentally
different than just random sampling from
a permutation and so that's kind of cool
because you know these values have come
with a lot of important properties and
people care about them a lot not just in
ml but elsewhere and so what's nice
about this is that it's not just a new
way but it's a way that can be helpful
so here you can see that permutation
samplings are just drawing from a
permutation is fairly high variance okay
so here I'm just drawing more and more
and more permutations which involves are
evaluating the original model more and
more and more so it's computationally
painful to do this and this shows the
sort of standard deviation of my
estimate over time and I have right here
the right answer for two different
models and - so this is an individual
feature estimating a value for it so a
permutation sampling has a high variance
if you look at lime it has a much lower
variance due to its regression
formulation but of course is not
converging to the values that we would
like based on these axioms so what we're
able to do with our width shop is
actually kind of have our cake and eat
it too so we get to keep the low
variance of a regression based
formulation but also converge to the
values we want so we get to keep the
axiomatic agreement
yeah I good questions so each of these
is just looking at the convergence of a
single feature this is looking at the
convergence in a dense model and this is
looking at the convergence in a sparse
model okay because in a sparse model
you're allowed to use regularization to
improve the convergence like lasso for
example for regression lots of tools of
regression that allow you to have better
sample power so this is kind of
demonstrating that and then this is just
a dense model where we don't get to use
any regularization but we still get a
lower variance so in this case I think
there was about 20 features and about
this one there is maybe 200 so yeah so
so this is fun and we will stop here and
do a quick review of where you've been
through so we're gonna talk about
applications
you know contributions in all these
areas but we just talked about in theory
a unification of explanation methods
right so we just talked about a wide
number of explanation methods that were
in the literature and how they all
connect together because they have the
same type of explanation that they
produce as an output and then we talked
about some strong uniqueness results
that now apply to the whole class and
allow us to go in to where we used to
make heuristic choices and instead have
theoretical basis for choosing
parameters such that we obey these
classic Shapley axioms and then in
practice this led to a new estimation
method for these classic Shapley values
it has lower variance and hence requires
less computation in order to explain
individual predictions from the models
at this point I want to move over to an
application of these techniques and this
is actually the application that
motivated all this work in the first
place and so kind of told the story in
Reverse if you will and the application
is anesthesia safety so several doctors
came to my adviser and Kingdom on myself
and they wanted to improve the safety of
anesthesia through machine learning and
I don't know if you guys have ever
stopped to think about it but anesthesia
is this wonderful thing that's only been
around for maybe 150 200 years or so and
wide broadly available sense and we've
made a lot of progress but it's there's
still more safety things to happen okay
it's still not a perfectly risk-free
event to keep you you know asleep but
not dead
so why would ml help here well the
operating room it turns out is a very
data rich environment okay it could be
one of the places you get the most data
recorded about you in a health sense in
your entire life if you go into an
operating room
there's tons of high-frequency
measurements from lots and lots of
sensors hooked up to you over a time
series and of course there's a lot of
background medical data that comes in as
well so the anesthesiologist who came to
us said if you could predict adverse
events just before they happened that
would allow us to be proactive being
proactive would help them better manage
the patient so the particular adverse
event they cared about here is hypoxemia
where this is low blood oxygen so
essentially this used to be the number
one cause of anesthesia related death
about 50 years ago but then these things
got pulse oximeter has got invented and
now you can actually see where the
status of the patient is in terms of
their hypoxemia or you know their blood
oxygen content and that just totally
revolutionized the safety of anesthesia
but it's still retrospective it's still
looking backwards and so if we could
just look maybe five minutes in the
future and guess we'll you have
hypoxemia in five minutes they can make
less severe interventions during the
care of patients in the hospital so we
built a system called prescient that
predicts hypoxemia again five minutes is
the number that the doctors gave us is
like this is about when kind of a time
range we'd like to know and then how
does it work well so it predicts
hypoxemia by taking a variety of input
so we have text data numeric data like
age categorical data and lots of other
you know all the different types of data
input you would think of except for
images and then we also have a bunch of
time series data coming in that's minute
by minute data coming in from u-dub and
Harborview here over the course of
several years so we have about eight
million minutes of training data that we
get to feed into this model so a large
number of minutes and then out of the
model we're predicting at every minute
the risk of the patient so at this time
we're predicting odds ratios for the
patient over time and this is forward in
time so this is five minutes negative
five minutes negative ten minutes in the
past and you can see their risk is going
up and down over time where the risk is
will they fall into this desaturation
region okay so this is the saturation of
o2 and it's pretty high and then it
dropped here so this is an actual
desaturation event and then we
here and the question is are you going
to have another desaturation event or
not again this is from an actual patient
and the risk right now is two point four
well here I do not know in this point
from this point the doctors are
constantly intervening so that is a good
a good question I mean in a no are it's
not like will I have done the
intervention it's like what are the
current interventions because they're in
like you're on a ventilator they're like
seven knobs that are set to certain
settings and I'll talk about some of
those knobs in just a moment but yeah
there are lots of possible interventions
there's lots of ongoing intervention so
this is definitely risk with respect to
the current standard of care it's
definitely what we're predicting and it
is varying over time yeah so the
prediction at the current moment is
about twice the normal likelihood and it
has recently gone up in the last couple
minutes okay but just like John or
John's boss the doctor has the same
question and you can see now why we got
pushed into model explained ability they
won't understand why well okay if you
want explain ability let's start with a
linear model maybe logistic regression
would be a great simple get the job done
kind of model and if we do that we could
produce an explanation in kind of an
odds ratio form right so here's 2.4 odds
ratio at the current moment and we could
express that as a product of terms if
we're doing logistic regression so let's
sort the term and we see the biggest
term is the fact that they're overweight
okay so the biggest risk factor for
having breathing problems or hypoxemia
issues is is overweight now that's
something I don't expect or hope is not
intervened on at this moment in the
hospital that's not gonna fix that
instantly the next one however is low
tidal volume and this is how much you're
breathing in and out so tidal volume is
essentially a knob sitting on the
ventilator how much air are we putting
in and out of your lungs and it turns
out that there was this spike here is
almost entirely driven by the doctors
setting of that knob now there are good
reasons to set the knob at a low setting
but this quantifies the risk that goes
into it very explicitly and that's what
doctors found very helpful much much
more helpful than just staring at a
number and wondering what's wrong in the
room somewhere there's some things of
course that help the patient in this
case their pulse is looking good and
then there's thousands of other features
that are pulled out of here all together
have
moderate effect okay so it turns out
that at each point there's going to be a
different set of features but those
features are going to be a fairly small
set of features that really are driving
the risk at this moment okay but maybe
we don't wanna use a linear model
because it turns out if we plot the ROC
curve you're familiar with this a higher
is better I thought the ROC curve for
the logistic regression model we were
just talking about and we got a
reasonable performance of point
eight-six but then if we throw a complex
model in this case gradient boosted
trees at this we get a significant jump
in performance this is a 15 percent jump
and the true positive rate if we fix our
FPR at point one and so that's a very
non-trivial change in the accuracy of
the system and we tried a lot of
marginal transformations to try and make
linear lasso work better but we did not
succeed so this left us with this
question of how do we best address this
trade-off okay and again that's what
pushed us in to explain ability methods
and led us to this understanding of
unity and kind of kept pulling that
string okay so now that we have pulled
that string we kind of came back to this
problem and said alright how would we
address this now that we have this
approach called shot well how will you
use these shot values in the operating
room well one way to convey these values
to a doctor for example would be to
start with the base value of one okay so
this is a auds ratio so this is normal
typical risk and then we can show you
your current risk of 2.4 and what we can
do is we can take all of the features
that are positive that is they're
increasing your risk and we can plot
them where the width of the bar is the
impact of that feature on your risk okay
so tidal volume has this much impact
height and weight and we can sort them
and you can see that there's almost all
of them have very little weight because
there's thousands of features here and
stacked against that we can see features
lowering your risk so the some of the
purple plus the green kind of pushing
against each other equals of course the
output 2.4 yeah
in between time-varying measures and
these kind of like BMI and other
contextual things that are going to be
the same throughout yeah that's true I
mean those are in the sense not
actionable so I don't know what the
right thing to do is because I don't
engage with doctors but I would think
that a distinction would be yeah so
there's two ways to at least that we
thought about that one was do we want to
actually go back into the time series
and try and figure out where in the time
series we're getting the signal okay
because in a time varying thing maybe
you know your tidal volume is actually
really a time series of things so you
could maybe try and tell me what part of
it we went into and some of the people
in my lab are actually working on that
is kind of an extension but we didn't do
that right away in terms of which ones
are intervene able and which ones are
not well I mean this is something that I
I'll talk about the user studies that we
did do on this but I think there's still
more questions to tease out there
because doctors almost instantly
recognize that right away when they see
it so I could of course label which ones
are affecting me and which ones are not
but they found it kind of nice to know
because they also in their head have a
risk model and they would like to see
even the onion terminable ones that they
have in their head they want to also see
here ya know that's a really good point
yeah exactly cuz the fact that your
tidal volume is an equal risk to the
fact that you're overweight suddenly
it's like something like well I've
pretty quantified as a doctor I know how
much I think this weight is affecting
you my turn of that knob is now equal to
that mmm that's interesting right yeah
yeah
[Music]
the likelihood of success how do you
even begin to bring those in so this is
I love this yeah but it's precondition
on the fact that I'm following one thing
and I care about that yeah no it's a
excellent question and essentially it's
saying how do you best kind of measure a
whole handful of outcomes or you know
dozens it outcomes potentially as you
constantly care about I think we thought
about that and said this is like I
agreed if totally where you want to be
when you're in a hospital setting
because you don't want them myopically
affecting one risk and totally messing
up another one yeah and so you know I
could hypothesize how best to display
that to doctors but I haven't actually
tested that so I'm not sure it'd be
helpful for me to - to go at it except
for the fact that of course you can run
many many of these models or train one
multitask model if you prefer and then
you're gonna have lots and lots of these
things showing up I think at some point
the real important point is people are
not gonna be staring at this all day
probably at some point you're gonna sort
of raise some morning or bring their
attention to something and I think that
should probably be one of like a whole
panel of things that you're interested
in and at some point one of those things
in the panel is gonna light up and
you're gonna go and look at it and at
that point we were trying to say all
right we want to explain at least what
the model was concerned about at that
moment so you can warn the number yeah
[Music]
my goal is reducing this yeah so what
you're asking is obviously what the
doctor wants I think the issue is
oftentimes we don't have that to give
them in a sense that this isn't the
causal model it's trained on historical
data
it's full of confounding and that's
actually one of the things going forward
that I think is a lot of open work here
I think there's a lot of I think in
order to properly interpret this model
you really probably have to have some
sort of causal graphical model sitting
in your head about we're all how all
these variables relate to one another
and you have to actually sit down in
front of this with experts before it
ever goes into the operating room and
look and see like you know peak pressure
actually helps people but you found it
hurt people because of an association
with some confounder that you didn't
think about that's all stuff that you
know needs to be sorted out before it
goes into the o.r and it has to be done
you know has to be done beforehand
because you can't expect people to do
that on the fly but that being said I
don't think like I'm not sure where the
boundary is but I I'm hesitant to hide
too much of the actual Association I
would rather probably tell them like I
don't know how to visualize this because
I really think that it's future work and
like how to integrate causal modeling
with this to help people not make causal
claims about things that are not causal
but I guess what we came away with was
oftentimes something could go wrong but
doctors are there for six hours and some
of these surgeries and there can be
really simple obvious things that would
be obvious if they were you know paying
a hundred percent attention for six
hours but they aren't otherwise and so
just seeing why the algorithm is
concerned can get you a long way there
but it's not gonna get you to causality
and so I think that if we wanted to
answer the causal question we would
actually have to be in the loop in order
for me to trust it at least we'd have to
be in the loop and they would have to be
some sort of like understanding of
what's randomized and what isn't and so
from our perspective we said well how
far can we get with an observational
study and that's where we're at here so
answer your question
yeah I just want to be as my explanation
based on things and I I'm in my mind
also like I don't have answers giving
this kind of an explanation versus
giving like a counterfactual actionable
whatever that is and it would be like I
guess good - it kind of do the same
observational studies with professionals
to see like how they are interpreting
yeah yeah I know I agree and I guess the
one thing we want to avoid is presenting
things that are observational as though
they were true counterfactual I agree
yeah and then I should expect to see
this just go down along those lines -
yep but perhaps maybe it's an easier
question so let's like maybe make the
assumption that this model is a
perfectly like perfect model and it
truly represents the real world in every
possible way
right I'm wondering like and maybe I
just missed this in the presentation
earlier but like how simulate able is
this as a doctor like like if I if I
know the kind of Shapley score I get
from tidal volume and I know that the
volume is 2 right now can I make
assumptions about what the model would
predict if I dropped the tidal volume to
1 right so I've got a black box model I
see a score like an attribution yeah
yeah - and I say okay I can turn this
knob down to one do I know how the model
would change is that valid what's the
questions that what one I'm gonna
postpone till later in the talk where we
actually try and understand the
individual features one at a time which
this plot does not tell you cuz that's
the first thing just by looking at this
all you know is what the current value
is doing however you can draw curves
with these things first you could of
course do a partial dependence bottom
right just literally drag the curve and
see it but it also turns out that you
can make interesting plots
using lots and lots of these
explanations and that's what I'll talk
about a little bit later so maybe ask
that question again when you see that
and then tell me if that answers it yeah
sure so I guess like the guidance is to
pick it based on your training data set
but if the people I'm evaluating on are
different than the people that I've seen
in the training set is there any yeah so
for examples go to a financial case it
might make a lot more sense to use the
sort of the background distribution not
to be your training data set but to be
the distribution of people who got alone
right now everything is with respect to
people who didn't who got loans here's
why I didn't get alone so I think it
really depends on kind of what is the
reference frame because whenever like if
you're sitting in a room as a doctor and
someone comes in and says I have a fever
and your risk for something goes up
that's because you mentally have some
kind of background model in your head of
like what the people in who typically
come into your office and if you live in
you know the jungle you might have a
different background distribution than
someone who lives in Alaska but you
should think the same way when you're
building this algorithm is like the
person has something in their mind you
would like your background distribution
to match their mental model as much as
possible okay all right I'm gonna move
really quickly I think 11:45 is that one
or trying to wrap up or one summer in
there I'm not sure the second time okay
all aim 45 and do that okay so to move
quickly here imagine so we have this
plot explaining an individual prediction
at individual point in time if you
rotate it 90 degrees and then you can
run it over time you get things that
look like this okay so essentially this
is going forward in time this is the
current time so this is actually this
slice right here and remember this
Junction is the current prediction so we
can look at the this is the prediction
the junction between green and purple
over time and we can see the area of
different features changing throughout
the course of the surgery and in fact
tidal volume is actually something that
it expands and then goes away and just
in this little piece right here and so
that tells us it's a transient effect at
this point in time due to the model and
then so this is kind of nice to see the
flow of
risk of a patient over time during a
surgery yeah that's right that's correct
yeah so if I'm looking at the individual
prediction I just sort them so title
volume may be here because it's really
big but over here it's going to be
buried somewhere in this tale and so
I'll never see it yeah so this is all
the features all the features are here
just some of them have larger widths
than others because they're more
important at that moment than others the
sort of here yeah yeah no there's no
crossovers here so I just sort by the
global importance and then you know for
title I'm it may be farther down in the
bundle that it pops out but it's just
sort of to roughly put like most of them
trying to tale well I mean what you're
explaining here is what the models
actually using so that would only
fluctuate if the model itself wasn't
actually randomly at each time point
picking different features well so
essentially you think about like there's
a model that is the there's a function
that is the model making prediction the
set of inputs let's say two of them are
very correlated and I want to know how
much do those inputs matter for my
output that depends a lot of a function
okay so it's a lasso maybe it only
picked one and nor the other one in
which case you'll never see one of them
in this plot because the model doesn't
actually touch it maybe it was a Ridge
model
you know Ridge regression you in that
case it would have spread them out
equally perhaps between the two and then
you would have seen both doing all the
same things together throughout the
whole plot but in order for them to swap
the model itself would have to change
from one time point to another we'd have
to have some sort of like if this then
that kind of statement like and that
would be very unlikely that okay sure
just a function you can evaluate and
it's essentially by breaking that
correlation and perturbing them
independently so essentially that's
that's deep into it I guess I don't know
if we should go into that conversation
at the moment but essentially it's
basically perturbing the inputs to the
model to understand that's how all black
box models have to understand the
function because there's no other way to
look inside it without making some
assumption about the internals but
ultimately that's what it's gonna happen
and so that's how it's gonna procure
what's going on and then assuming that
your model is consistent you'll get
consistent explanations across time so
we tested how this worked by going back
and replaying historical data to set up
anesthesiologist practicing
anesthesiologist that you dub in her
view and you demand Children's Hospital
and we showed them cases both with and
without assistance by prescients and
then asked them to anticipate on a scale
of 1 to 100 risk in the next 5 minutes
so that allowed us to make our seekers
not as for questions but also for the
doctors and not just doctors but doctors
with and without help with prescients
and so if we do that we can do is run
that for all 5 doctors and then average
their ROC curves to get the solid green
curve here and we can do the same thing
when they were assisted by prescience
and get a blue curve and it's hard to
say exactly what the false positive rate
of a doctor is and you know because they
don't have that in their head but let's
assume that they anticipate 15% then
that provides a very significant
improvement you
their ability to anticipate which we
were encouraged by yeah exactly and
that's because you know once you get
lower in lower false positive rates you
know this we didn't want to kill off the
doctors by asking them to run forever
yeah yeah and so that's why we kind of
highlighted these things here and tried
to pick at FPR high enough that we were
confident with this distal separation
which is significant in that case and
then this is something we wrote up you
can read about more in nature be me I'm
gonna move fairly quickly here to make
it through the rest of this stuff but
there's still room for improvement here
okay and why is there room for
improvement because have you just talked
about model agnostic methods can only
explain models by perturbing your inputs
and observing how their output changes
it's really the only way that you can
explain things if you don't make any
assumptions about what's inside them but
you know how does that hurt us well it
turns out if you want to explain a whole
data set it can be inconvenient to do
this okay so let's imagine we're trying
to explain a whole data set just with a
very fast model so this is gonna be
actually boost and so inference on you
know sets of trees is very quick but
here's what we're doing is we're having
simulated data and were essentially
increasing the number of features in our
model so that we can control that all
these features really matter
and then we're training an excuse model
and then we're explaining 10,000
predictions and what you can see is this
as minutes of runtime and it's just a
linear increase as you might expect the
number of features because I have to do
this for each feature essentially
perturb things and this is the lower
bound it's just the time to run the
model so whatever estimation stuff you
do on top it's in addition and here
we're talking a couple hours by the time
we're up to 90 really important features
which is certainly doable for a whole
dataset of 10,000 predictions but it's
it's unpleasant and would totally change
the way a data scientist does their
workflow and it's not that we were using
too many samples either so this is the
previous permutation sampling approach
that we've talked about and then this is
the new one the regression based
approach the lower variance but still a
couple percent of the magnitude of these
bars are twiddling around a little bit
so it's not non-trivial you have to
think about the fact that there is noise
there's this balancing act that's going
on so if we go back to what we did for
an np-hard problem there really is a
third option and that is we can restrict
the problem definition okay so we don't
have to solve this for all possible fun
Asians we can maybe just solve it for a
class of functions which is very
attractive in the context of machine
learning because machine learning models
come in classes many of which are very
popular so we decided to choose the
class of trees and this leads to a kind
of a new estimation method for these
classic shap the guys for tree based
machine learning models so why do we
pick trees not just because we were
using them but also because other people
it turns out are using them this is
Cagle 2017 they basically asked data
scientist at work
what are you use for your machine
learning models not surprisingly
logistic regression is right up there at
the top but then if you look at its
random forest decision trees and samba
models gradient boosted machines all of
these involve or are totally dependent
on trees so there's a tree based machine
learning models so whenever you're
thinking of explaining a complex model
people typically think a nonlinear model
so that means almost all the nonlinear
models that are deployed and used
currently in practice today are based on
trees so if we can make significant
advances on this class of models that
will impact a lot of current
applications so how will we do this well
let's imagine we want to explain it
directly with no sampling what would we
be facing well we have tea trees in our
in Samba let's say and each of them has
L leaves and then we have M input
features so now we have M factorial
because they have all these permutations
we want to do and then we still have
computer expectations so that's another
sample however many end you want to draw
in order to compute that expectation so
that's factorial it turns out there's a
way to rephrase it as exponential but
we're not really much closer to
tractability yet but then now we can
restrict ourselves to the class of trees
and it turns out there's a fairly cool
but involved algorithm it's a recursive
method that I won't go through today and
it's interesting because of course the
solution here depends on an exponential
number of conditional expectations but
they fall out in the trees in such a way
that we can design an algorithm that's
TLD squares or D is the depth of the
trees so this means tiao is just linear
time so that's number of nodes and all
the trees and then d squared is the
depth and this polynomial time runtime
gives us exact solutions just like you
had done this which is very nice because
now we don't have any of the problems
you had before in fact if we plot the
runtime of our new method against the
lower bound for the agnostic methods
it's like indistinguishable from zero
which
is nice and of course there's absolutely
no explanation variability so if you're
a data scientist who's thinking about
explaining your model suddenly this
thing is done in seconds and you never
have to worry about sampling variability
which really changes how people can use
this stuff and it turns out it matters
too because if you think about well so
we think about trees you might think
well trees have been around for a long
time like we should know how to explain
trees by now right there they've been
studied for quite a while and a lot of
people have looked into explaining
understanding feature importance in
trees but almost always people are
thinking about global feature importance
what is the importance of this feature
over my whole model over my whole
training data set you know gain geni
importance permutation importance these
are all things that are global feature
importance methods and there's only one
approach that we found kind of heuristic
layout in their literature to explain an
individual prediction from a tree which
is what we need for John oh and even our
medical examples etc and their heuristic
and they're inconsistent so how do we
mean inconsistent okay so this goes back
to that those two properties right we
had local accuracy and consistency
consistency is one of those properties
you want to hold and here's an example
of when it fails and this is from the
heuristic methods we have for trees
right now so here is a set of and
functions okay so my model is very
simple it's just an and function take
some binary inputs all independent and
it just says if they're all true one
they're all false zero okay a two way a
three way a four way all the way up to
ten way and functions and then if I was
to be consistent of course I'd have to
allocate credit fairly between them and
if my background is typically zero then
I'm going to just split up my 1.5 and
point five for two thirds fourths fifths
etc so this is like we know the right
answer because it's such a simple model
but then what we do is we say well let's
run the heuristic methods well we get
something very different it turns out
that most of the credit actually goes to
the leaves of the tree just the way that
this method works and it's actually very
similar to the gain method and
essentially as you go down the tree the
purer and purer your group gets all
sudden you get more and more gains for
for getting it done and so this is
exactly the opposite of what you want
because these are probably the most
important features because you greedily
selected them for your
rebuilding but by the time you get to
like a depth for an function almost no
credit is going to the route and almost
all of its ending up in the leaves so
this is a definition of inconsistency
okay and when we have our fast tree
shape of course it identically produces
exactly this because it comes with
guarantees so this is one strong
motivation for using these values over
what we had before another one is to
basically go back and say well with lots
of metrics out there for that we can use
to measure the performance of a local
explanation method particularly ones
that are assigning numbers to their
inputs so a local feature attribution
kind of thing
no individual metric is going to be like
the right metric but there are many ways
to go about it and so what we did is we
defined lots of metrics that I'm not
gonna go into the details of all of them
but they're all about perturbing or
removing features and just seeing did I
get the right one did I get you said
that was positive okay I'll take it out
did your main thing go down okay etc and
and then we're gonna plot that against
lots of explanation methods designed
specifically for trees okay so we're not
looking at model agnostic ones
necessarily we're just looking at the
tree based ones and when we then look at
our exact explanations for trees we call
tree explainer we can see it
consistently performs well across all
these metrics you know in general which
we found very encouraging both for like
a decision tree and a random forest and
we also tested this on grading boost of
trees so I think this sort of broad kind
of benchmark sort of evaluation means
that these axiomatic things are not just
nice properties may also lead to
practical improvements in the
explanations you get another thing that
we found actually surprising and we
weren't actually setting out to do was
you can of course take local
explanations and put them back together
to get a global one right because take
the mean absolute value or if I'm
explaining the loss function I can just
take the mean of the loss for example
and when we do that we can get a single
number but now we were doing this sort
of axiomatically motivated act abuse ins
for each individual explanation so when
we put them back together turns out we
get better feature selection power than
previous approaches you know like game
permutation game is like Genie
importance if you're more familiar with
that term so these are the ways that
people do feature importance for trees
today which is fairly widely used in a
lot of domains and so we found it pretty
surprising that this
a simulated data set we pulled from some
other paper that was using to check
feature selection power and this is when
the interactions are minimum and you can
see if reasonable jump both of the
decision tree and with a random forest
so we found that kind of surprising and
nice who actually got better global
feature selection power when we went
back to global from our local methods
the last thing we checked was he said
well these are explanations so they
should probably be consistent with human
intuition and how can we measure that
well what we can do is go back to these
simple functions like and/or an
exclusive or things like this and these
are things people in theory if explained
well should understand themselves like
they know how the whole thing works and
then you can ask them how would you
define credit how would you allow fairly
allocate credit among the input features
and if you do that for an and function
unsurprisingly this is an and function
mixed with some additive effects they
fairly divide it between fever and cough
which is part of a story problem that we
used a Mechanical Turk to kind of get
people to understand what this model was
doing of course I didn't tell it was a
machine learning model and then we can
compare that to the shap values that we
get which nicely line up with human
intuition but then we can compare that
to the heuristic values and get
significant differences and this
significant difference happens not just
for an but for or exclusive or all the
kind of nonlinear functions so it agrees
when you have a linear function but
otherwise we see significant Delta's
between what we observed on a consensus
from a Mechanical Turk studies on simple
models which is another reason that we
thought we should prefer these shep eyes
so in review for trees we've narrowed in
on particular type of models trees we
have really fast exact computation
methods that allow this to be very
practical they come still with these
attractive theoretical guarantees
because we're not doing any
approximations now they have really good
performance across a broad breadth of
explainable lian metrics surprisingly
they actually improve global feature
selection power which is kind of fun and
they have the strong consistency with
human intuition so using all that thing
all those results we basically said can
what can we do with this how can we use
these to kind of improve our ability to
do machine learning in practice and so
we built a set of explainable AI tools
to do that so
to do to kind of explore this let's look
at a couple data sets this one here is a
classic data set called n hangs one from
the 1970s it's a very classic you know
about 20,000 people in the United States
were given lots of standard medical
tests and then 20 years later they were
followed up for mortality so we can
train a Cox proportional hazards model
with Raney boosted trees in this case to
predict mortality over in the US in the
1970s so again as I say we can take the
mean absolute value to get a global
future importance and if we do that we
can learn like what's the number one
risk factor for death in the 1970s in
the United States the drumroll is H big
surprise well what was more surprising
to me at least in magnitude was that the
number two killer was being a guy and
then after that comes the things you
might think about in terms of blood
pressure inflammation you know body mass
and a whole bunch of other things okay
so this is what you would get if you
just explained a model today maybe not
with the theoretical guarantees but you
would get bar plots like this you just
said about future importance from one of
these things but now that we have
explanations for each individual sample
we can do better than just put a bar
chart here okay because one thing this
bar chart does is it conflates the
prevalence of an effect with the
magnitude of an effect and whenever you
have a global feature measure you have
to come up with one number so you have
to pick a trade-off and somehow combine
these two things together and that's
really important because we often want
to find rare high magnitude effects in a
population you could of course train
lots of models on lots of subsets of
your population and then look at their
global future importance but now we can
actually look at each individual in the
population look for groups of people
that have high magnitude even though
those may be a small group of people so
as an example let's go down to the one
at the bottom of our list here called
blood protein if you look at this you
think well maybe the global importance
is fairly low so maybe this is a very
you know not important factor for life
expectancy what we can do over here is
on the x-axis we're gonna plot our
feature impact our shap value so
negative is good
meaning it's lowering your risk positive
is bad it's essentially years of life in
a linear sense on this scale and what we
can do is you plot a dot for every
person because for every person we're
going to have a
you assigned to their blood protein
measurement like a tribunal signed to it
and then we gonna color those dots by
the actual blood protein so we can see
whether it's high or low and when we do
that if we do like a little you know bee
swarm style plot where the dots pile up
to show density we can see a long tail
stretching off to the right here of red
dots so there's a pile up here right at
zero which means for almost everybody
their blood protein has no impact on
their risk for mortality at least with
respect to the general US population but
for these people like for that
particular person right their blood
protein is extremely important it's
probably the most important factor in
their life expectancy perhaps and these
rare high magnitude effects are things
that pop out when you can explain
everything at an individual level across
the population now you could say well of
course we could do that before but it's
really nice now that we have these very
high speed
you know trustable explanation
approaches for trees because this makes
us really practical because we can
quickly explain whole datasets and then
plot them like this we can do this for
all the features and if we do we see
interesting trends so here on the right
side you'll see there's lots of ways to
die young by being way out of range okay
so these are people with very high blood
pressure this is someone these are
actually very underweight people you
know there's lots of reasons to be out
of range but in case you're looking
around and browsing articles online
there's not a lot of ways to be wildly
out of range and somehow live way longer
so I would urge skepticism except be
young okay
so you can be young that's I guess the
best way but these are like insights
that come when we tease apart prevalence
and magnitude of effect okay and we can
do that now that we've explained
individual samples but we also might
want to zoom in closer on one of these
features and understand more about it
and so one way we could do that is to
literally put that features value on the
x-axis kind of like a partial dependent
spot would be but instead of scrubbing
things around on a PDP plot instead what
we're gonna plot now is the shap value
for that feature on the y-axis so for
every excellent every person they're
going to have the impact of their value
and the actual value of their systolic
blood pressure we plot them we get this
so this looks very much like the
standard curve of risk you would get for
standard systolic blood pressure stuff
so here's 120
higher than 120 you start going up in
your risk of mortality but what you
notice is that there's dispersion here
right this is not like a PDP pot we just
get a line now as a vertical dispersion
and this dispersion is driven by
interaction effects in your model if you
had a linear model you would never see
any vertical dispersion but what this
means is a lot of people with blood
pressure of 180 but for that person it's
less concerning them for that person the
question is why why is it more
concerning for someone than someone else
well it turns out I don't have time to
go into the details but you can extend
the ideas from game theory about putting
attribution on individual features you
can extend that to interactions of any
order but what we did is we implemented
it with this algorithm a high speed way
to compute the interactions for all
pairwise interactions so now we're
essentially assigning credit not just
among like a vector of feature
attributions but a matrix of feature
attributions where the diagonal is the
main effects and the off diagonal is all
your pairwise interactions and when we
do that now we can look in and see well
what are the interactions that are here
and what's driving that and it turns out
in this case is H so now we can color by
age in order to see what's the effect
here and we can see that this is
highlighting how early onset high blood
pressure is much more dangerous than
late onset high blood pressure in terms
of your mortality risk and we don't need
to go into all the medical reasoning
behind that but I think this is
something that you know kind of
highlights again another example of when
you have lots and lots of local
explanations that you trust you can pull
out signal from your data that you might
not otherwise have seen from models that
would have otherwise been considered
opaque in this case like depth six
decision trees several thousand of them
now I said we had interaction effects so
we could also plot a feature let's say
age on the x-axis and here we can plot
one of the off-diagonal things in our
interaction matrix this time between age
and sex and if we do that we'll see the
varying impact of being men versus women
over a lifetime so here we have you know
risk being fairly stable and then they
cross and peak at age 60 which when we
talk to doctors was you know strikingly
similar to when cardiovascular risk also
Peaks which is predominantly affecting
men it's not causal so I don't know
exactly what's driving it but these are
the types of very interesting interact
that just pop out from you know just
plotting many many local explanations in
this case from a GBM tree well so what's
happening here is remember this is the
off-diagonal effects there's always a
main effect that shows that women are
always better off than men but this is
going to of course be centered because
its main effect is subtracted to mean so
by definition it's simply showing the
relative difference mm-hmm so once I
know this one I kind of know this one
last thing I want to end on here is
probably actually one of the more fun
applications of this stuff and it comes
from when you have machine learning
models and you deploy them it turns out
they break I know if you ever heard this
but it turns out sometimes they have
problems likes most software bugs show
up like things features drift like
someone changed something in the data
pipeline that messed up the way the
thing got deployed and no one knew and
you know sometimes that costs a lot of
money depending on what pipeline we're
talking about so in a hospital that
doesn't well it could cost money or
lives depending on what your what you're
looking at and so we're asking how can
we you know better improve the safety
profile of ML models when they're used
in high stakes decisions we can talk
about model monitoring in a hospital so
what one popular thing people do with ml
models and hospitals is try and predict
the duration of things so they can do
better scheduling that's fairly benign
tasks so here we're predicting the
duration of procedures in a hospital
over the course of five years so this is
data from u-dub and Harborview and we
use the first year of data for training
yes we trained to predict based on all
the kind of static features how long is
this procedure going to take so what
doctors and how long do they need to be
scheduled and then what you can see of
course is a natural jump in error once I
do train tests so and this is training
error this is test error it's just
naturally higher but if you just look at
this over time you're like well I don't
know if I know models doing great or not
but this is typically what people do is
they just look at the loss of my model
over time and see is it going down is it
going up and you would never see if
there was a problem here unless it
we destroyed your model and to
demonstrate that we actually introduced
a bug into the model here like we
actually went in and we changed the
codes of two rooms in the hospital so
it's really easy change that could
happen in any data pipeline just swap
the names of those two rooms and you
know can you you know this training was
his test can you see where we introduced
the bug of course the answer is no
there's no and you could guess what you
guess in your head but then what we can
do well before I show you that I guess
already did I was like I can't take it
away now it's already there what we do
is we said let's explain the loss of the
model okay so not the output of the
model but the loss you know if we
explain the loss of the model with these
shap values what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take that value which is the loss
and we're gonna allocate it among the
input features we're just going to say
for each of these input features how
much did you hurt or helped the loss of
my model and of course I can do that on
every single input prediction so I'll do
that that'll essentially deconvolve my
loss backwards through the model onto
the input features and then I can look
at these individual input features and
room number six was one of the ones that
we swapped the question now is so red
I've colored the ones where this room is
on so they're in the room and blue is
whether or not and so it's not very
informative to know when they aren't in
the room because there's lots of rooms
in the hospital but when they are in the
room you can see it's typically lowering
the error of the model so it's got a
negative value that means it's lowering
the loss and then all of a sudden here
now it's hurting the law it's hurting
loss hurting the loss hearing loss and
so if you look up here you'd never know
that this bug had been introduced into
your model pipeline but if you look down
here you can see a very clear signal
that it pops up and importantly you
might be able to find this by just model
you know monitoring the input statistics
of your data because that's basically
what people do today for my
understanding in order to monitor models
they look at this and look at the input
statistics of your data over time but if
these rooms had equal usages you would
never see a change in the input
statistics they're marginals look the
same but the effect on the models
prediction is quite dramatic not in the
overall sense because there are many
procedures happening all over these
hospitals but it's certainly hurting a
lot of the predictions you know hundreds
if not thousands of predictions are
impacted by this so this I think is
really interesting and could really be
helpful in
basically taking explainable UI and
using it to impact model monitoring in
practice now it's not just bugs that we
introduced so this is actually a batch
data that was in theory cleaned but of
course you know data's never fully
cleaned so what we found was you know we
just plotted this for lots of features
and I just pulled out a few examples
that were interesting here's one where
we plot are you under general anesthesia
it's a flag in the electronic medical
record turns out somehow it was wildly
unhelpful for the algorithm right in
here for like a subset of the rooms in a
subset of one of the hospitals that's
something you would never found
otherwise turns out we went back and we
found out it was because of some
transient EMR connection issue between
various things exactly the kind of thing
that you would want to fix if you're in
the middle of it because it's hurting
your prediction performance here's one
where we actually observe drift over
time okay so this is another a binary
feature where we're saying are you under
the doing are you undergoing atrial
fibrillation ablation this is like a
procedure where they zap a part of your
heart in order to like stop a fib from
happening and this is we're trying to
predict the duration and what you can
see is a general upward trend where you
know particularly a training period but
also in the early test deployment
we're helping things and by the time we
get to the end of it this procedures
duration has actually changed we went
back to the hospital in the cardiology
department and they're like oh well
actually you know different people came
in and we got new technology and we're
much faster now well that's nice that's
great for the patients but it's bad for
the ml model because now you're features
changed and again the marginal statistic
won't have changed at all so another
example of how you can use this stuff so
to review this I'm gonna wrap it up here
in theory we talked about how we could
unify a variety of explanation methods
into a single class okay and that gave
us insights and how they were related we
talked about strong uniqueness results
from game theory that now kind of spread
to that whole class that we connected
together and how that can help us pick
new parameters and it's not just sort of
for the theoretical perspective but also
impacts practice because we have a new
way of estimating these values through
regression instead of simply random
sampling and that applies for blackbox
models and then we also proposed a new
way of estimating these in a very
high-speed way exactly for tree
based on these things we're then able to
build a whole set of explainable AI
tools that help you build you know and
monitor and understand the models that
you're building particularly if you're
using these trees it's very convenient
and we talked about a variety of
applications the motivating one that
started us down this track I mean this
eases safety and also some work in
mortality risk and hospital scheduling
demonstrating how these tools work in
practice so I'd like to highlight that
you don't have take my word for it you
can obviously try it yourself
it's on github it's also actually it
supports and is directly integrated into
extra boost like GBM which is a
Microsoft thing can't boost and
scikit-learn these are all tree based
integrations for this fast tree model
implemented in C++ and there's a whole
bunch of stuff that we did working on
deep learning models you know let's
assume the class of deep learning models
what can we do that I didn't talk about
but we have integrations with tensor
flow carrots and pi torch was also you
know as we said we started with hospital
kind of medical problems that kind of
got us down this road but it turns out
it got used all over the place you know
you stick things on github who knows
what they'll do with it turns out you
can help optimize performance of sports
teams Microsoft actually uses it in
their cloud pipeline right now as does
Google Cleveland Clinic uses it for like
identifying different subtypes of
cancers I thought was kind of cool close
to what we started with it's been used
for optimizing like manufacturing
processes for a jet engine stuff like
trying they build complicated models and
trying figure out like what's breaking
and why I had a chance to work with a
very very large international financial
banking stuff and this was really fun
because I actually got to go in and help
them do like kind of augmented
intelligence kind of stuff where we
basically said they have models and they
have people and at a certain risk
threshold they use people not models but
you don't want to lose everything that
the model had when you transition over
to people and so I got to work with them
for I did consulting with them
essentially to help them use these
values to help better essentially
collaborate between humans and machines
for their decision-making in financial
risk prediction it's also been used for
economics research and a bunch of other
stuff so I'm gonna skip over well I
won't step over future work
what's next but there's a lot of places
to go from here as you can probably
imagine a lot of fun things in theory
there's a lot of fundamental difference
interpretability trade-offs that exist
when you have correlated features okay
so you kind of touched on this a little
bit but sometimes you have to decide am
I going to violate my data or am I going
to understand my model actually did so
some fun well trade-offs that I think
will be really interesting there's a lot
of interesting work that's going on that
I'm involved with actually back in our
lab too and using explanation
constraints to guide model training it's
a really kind of a whole new way of
saying do the model is doing something
but do it this way such that your
explanation is like this and that's our
really fun way of doing things in
practice I think there's a lot of a lot
of work like this model monitoring stuff
is kind of fairly new and I think
there's a lot of things that we can do
there to make that much more practical
and usable to a large number of people
it's also I think when we're talking
about actually deploying stuff into
hospitals like causal structure and
assumptions and if you have causal
modeling assumptions that's essentially
expert knowledge that needs to be
integrated into these systems before you
ever put it in a hospital so you don't
expect people to like suddenly think
about how a confounding could happen on
the spot and applications always talked
about the financial one with high-stakes
decision-making hospitals are always
very similar same kind of like I have an
AI and I am here and I need to make a
decision how can you help me we're doing
a lot of interesting things
understanding adverse drug interactions
and stuff with genomics and stuff with
understanding protein folding with these
are all ongoing collaborations here at
u-dub and I think I talked about the
finance stuff so I'm going to skip over
this because I'm out of time but all
this work of course has been close
collaboration with my advisers who in
here at u-dub I've had the opportunity
to mentor number of younger grad
students and PhD program here also some
in math as well as the MD ph.d program
here at u-dub so there are a lot of
papers that we're working on together
both from like basic genomics research
to better understanding time series data
to estimating drug drug interactions
that just talked about that even cancer
stuff and of course there's always
external collaborations to make any of
this sort of medical stuff happen you
can't do that on your own so we've
worked with some great anesthesiologist
at Children's
u-dub and Harborview as well as stuff I
didn't talk about it all I had to do
with kidney Research Institute here in
Seattle just zero that's great work
there cardiology and then a bunch of
work that I didn't talk about because of
time but we had fun things learning
large-scale graphical models to
understand genomics with some people at
University of Toronto so thanks